Now, depending on how you look at this, this is either a very humbling
or very awe-inspiring moment.
One one hand, the laws that govern the chaos and disorder and confusion
that people see on earth are the same that govern the motions of the heavens.
But looking at it another way, the laws that govern the perfection of the motion of the heavens
are the same that control the chaos and disorder on earth.
It's either very scary or very beautiful depending on how you look at it,
but either way it must have been a very exciting time in physics.
Now that we've examined gravity a little bit,
we can start to think more about motion.
Now we're accepting gravity as a law of nature.
All objects are mutually attracted to one another.
And so when we think of a falling apple, we can draw an arrow
which represents the force of gravity, and I've used the subscript g is indicate
that this force is due to gravity.
From Galileo, we know exactly how this object will move.
It's going to accelerate downwards at 10 m/s².
What's really fascinating, though, is that eventually
this apple will hit the ground and come to rest.
So, let's think about this apple, this motionless apple at rest and think
about what does it mean for an object to be motionless?